A dear friend of mine is not managing your diabetes very well with sugars, often around 300.
That's not that on cover with diabetes. Also more recently, blood pressure issues over 200
over 70. That's not good. Blood pressure meds take, make her dizzy and have other side effects,
so not taking it as often as recommended. And really, the statistics on blood pressure
medication, unfortunately, they really only bring the blood pressure down about 10 points.
That's not very much. There's other alternative functional things to do with that that
actually work much better. Do you have regimens? You suggest on your site any suggestions
that how to proceed, not allopathic way, for diet for diabetes, but not sure how to proceed.
I know there's a lot to ask, but it is, it is very serious. And this person has to get very
serious about their diet. So, yeah, I don't think I have a whole lot about diabetes yet in the
automobile course. I'm going to be adding a bunch of stuff about it. You have a ton of stuff
about heart disease in the blog. I have a whole series called functional cardiology
that talks about heart disease. I think there's a series of five or six or seven blogs about
that go into depth about functional cardiology and what happens with your blood vessels and what
you can do to help with that. I don't know if that would be helpful to her.
Definitely, if she doesn't have cancer, she should be on an atroxide product
that would be the most helpful for her. They really wouldn't help with the diabetes, but it would
help with the blood pressure. Diabetes is a difficult thing to manage because it's damaged
cell membranes and then cells that are reproducing cells that have damaged cell membranes.
And it's not an easy thing to fix. You know, for blood sugars opera, there she probably does have to
investigate insulin as an intervention because ultimately she's going to have glycolytic
plaquing on her arteries. That's probably why she's got the high blood pressure and glycolytic plaquing
in her brain and not to be scary in global doom, but this is definitely what leads to early dementia.
So both Parkinson's with its corebitities and Alzheimer's, Alzheimer's has been suggested to be
diabetes type three because it has so much tied to diabetes type two.
Rife raised it down to 20 points and that's encouraged. I will be adding a bunch of stuff
in by this fall on diabetes in the chronic disease autoimmune course. I'm going to just continue
to add to that course. So you could look at that. This person can also make do a case review with us
with me too and I can help put together a protocol for as well. So